i've always really enjoyed ryan long's
comedy i think it's very very funny but
increasingly it is taking on the
character
of prophecy
and you you've seen this before
with his sketches about i don't know the
vaccines or rebeccovitt or about wokeism
or whatever but he did one that was
really on the money ryan
did a master class
on a
neocon defense contracting war criminal
nation-building type of individual and i
don't know like five minutes later
master class announces that it is in
fact hosting a class with hillary
clinton this i don't know how unless he
has a crystal ball he could have known
this ryan thank you for coming on hey
yeah what would she say she's a in the
trailer she was doing the speech that
like would have been
and that crazy
that's like a dude yeah you get married
and then like the divorce goes and you
go you give a class on marriage and you
go you know this is the speech i almost
gave at my wedding before this would
have been my 50th anniversary speech
that the toast at our party
yeah we broke up after two years fairly
dramatically actually but had we made it
to 50 years this is the kind of stuff i
would have been saying you know this
brings up actually one of my favorite
sketches that you did recently that
it was hilarious but it got to a really
important philosophical and
anthropological point that men do not
appreciate
it was on the phrase one of my least
favorite phrases in the english language
happy wife
happy life
yeah there was a
base in the the gist was the guy that
just consistently says happy wife happy
life and by the end of it you're just
like 100 a simp because obviously
yeah i mean there's obviously a point
underneath where
any proper working relationship with
like a person or you know a wife or
whatever they're you're gonna have to um
argue to some degree but i find that
what people do dudes they go
they'll like bottle it all in and just
take it take it take it and then just
blow up and they go i'm putting my foot
down and then you got to make some big
stink about nothing when really it was a
hundred issues at the same time where
it's like if you just no just be kind of
cool all the time be like hey what's
going on here you know this you have
like a fight about something but you let
it go and then it's like the girl that
uh says hey you i don't want you going
out with your friends on tuesday and you
go whatever and then you know she's like
no thursday and then by the end of it
you're like she goes i i i need you to
come uh because my my mom's getting
married again and you come to the
wedding and you go i am going out didn't
that you end up making us think of it
something ridiculous because i
have my wig night and i will change for
not that you pushed me to the edge this
is it if you i am i am putting my
knuckles on the floor and dragging
because you don't need to be a knuckle
dragger the the
just to your point the phrase
is not even true if if happy wife happy
life means appease your wife in all of
her unreasonable and disordered demands
and desires that will that will not make
your life happy it won't make her life
happy either it's just and
the guys who tell me happy wife happy
life
they're generally not the happiest guys
this is even why they have awesome wives
yeah like or it's a dude that his wife
kind of rules and he's you know happy
wife happy life you're like well yeah
easy to use it you're to say like she's
pretty reasonable yeah
you don't have that battle axe you know
that i've got hanging around this is why
i'm i'm skeptical of man caves even look
some man caves they're very beautiful i
like you know they some of my friends
have incredible man caves so i like that
but the idea of the man cave
is that you okay you you don't have any
place in your house
you you have to go to a subterranean
dungeon so that you can watch football
and eat wings or whatever because your
your wife will just banish you if you
tried it what happened to a man's home
is his castle you know what the i always
it's always like a matching thing even
with employees because i have like some
bodies that are pushover guys you know
whatever certain people it's like it's
not always the bad characteristic a lot
of times it's why people like them
because they're you know kind of down
for whatever right but in this in like
those kind of scenarios and people are
always like well you need to put your
foot down like don't take [ __ ] from her
it's like the truth is if you're the
type of guy that's always you know
agreeable like that what you really need
is to find like a nice person that
doesn't take advantage of people like
that
you know i mean i see some of these like
crazy girls i'm like i think i can
handle that because i'm down i'm like
the type of guy that's like i'm down to
argue if you want to argue let's argue
but if you're if you're the type of guy
that's not you need to find a person
that's like uh that's not gonna take
advantage of you non-stop that's right
rather than totally change your own
personality you just need to not marry a
predator yeah that this is well you know
there's this weird thing right i was
just talking to my friend michael anton
who's a great political philosopher and
writer over at claremont
and he pointed out that we're living in
kind of upside-down world right now
in this very unprecedented time where
everything
uh that is is supposedly beautiful is
actually ugly and you look at it on the
billboards and you know even lingerie
models now you look at a billboard in
times square and it's like the ugliest
fattest most grotesquely naked person
have no chill in this country right it's
it went straight from
uh there's no moderation it went from
every model looks like a twig and she's
puking out breakfast lunch and dinner
like you know i mean i gotta go throw up
because i ate a grape to like i'm
modeling the biggest piece of fabric in
the history of the world
there's no in between no balance i guess
we were just very extreme because i was
trying to think you know it it hit me
with it hit me with the marriages
because we went from this world in which
a man's home is his castle and you know
man is the ruler of the roost to if a
man ever expresses an opinion in his
home that he he's basically a psychopath
patriarch it needs to be booted to the
street same thing with comedy um
in comedy now we're told that you know
jokes are
not their jokes are not funny but
nanette and that woman the least funny
woman of all time is that's she's the
funniest woman ever and that tragedy
actually is the new comedy and then it
just got me thinking about the the
billboards and like even the buildings
you know hideous brutalist buildings are
beautiful buildings and all the
beautiful classical architecture in dc
basically has to be knocked down it's
like i sort of live like a weird pirate
life and a lot of it comes to like
normalizing outliers where it's like you
know that's actually the good thing but
it never it doesn't really help because
even if you think of nanette like yeah i
guess they like pushed it but it also
that created like such a backlash what
it always does right but you know that
show okay there's this show love island
yeah it's like girl show right and it's
like a bunch of hot people right and so
they've always on these shows that are
essentially a bunch of hot people they
pick the people they've been trying to
introduce like you know
non-traditionally attractive people and
like pretty decent looking for normal
but so they'll have like supermodels
supermodel supermodel
walmart customer supermodel right
and then so the dudes don't want to get
in trouble so you see the guys they kind
of go up and they go you know everyone
was good i felt that i had a bit more of
attraction with the five supermodels
gotta be honest so
you're like who is this helping and then
every year a girl like kills herself
because they get bullied on the internet
and the show kind of is like bullying's
bad but also it's like if you said a 12
year old was like pretty good at
basketball right and then you put them
in the nba and then every day you were
like he's the best player in the nba
everyone be like yo i hate this 12 you
know what i mean and all of a sudden
everyone's like talking trash on the 12
year old and then the kind of idea is
like why are you guys being mean it's
like no because they're mad that this
thing's getting like pushed in their
face so i don't know if you try to just
like upset like reality too much i think
it generally kind of backlashes even
when you're talking about the you can't
say jokes and stuff like the truth is
like there's probably more of a like a
want for people to hear like wild stuff
when you do comedy clubs because of that
you know because people feel like maybe
you can't stay at a jobs or whatever
whereas probably the
in the 90s or whatever when it was like
most accepted there was almost like a
genre of like the wild comedy like we're
saying outrageous stuff it was almost
gross like it's kind of like when you do
like an edgy show and they go this is
the like edgy we're seeing everything
and then you like your instinct there is
like i don't want to say it now that's
gross no well this is that was what norm
mcdonald did at the bob saget roast
right everyone was just saying all these
filthy disgusting anatomical things and
norm gets up and does a joke about how
saggett's head looked like cauliflower
and he was doing all these like dean
martin rose jokes and it totally
subverted so actually that yeah that's
the exact that's like the perfect
reference it really is then that's the
like mechanism because he's you know
he's saying the whole thing is it's the
funniness stems from in that genre like
the opposite of what expected once it's
like really expected it just feels
disgusting to do so you know i was
joking at the top about how you're
nostradamus and you keep kind of calling
these things
yeah well i think the the reason for
this is a priest friend of mine from new
york pointed out that prophets are not
people who have a crystal ball and they
predict the future prophets are just
observing the world as it is
while other people are imagining a world
that no longer is and so they're just
observing reality and then this seems
like they're predicting the future
because they're telling the truth in a
world full of lies so
what does that mean for us the fact that
you you seem to be predicting all of
these things nostradamus please tell me
what do we have to look forward to
well you i think there is something to
be said about
or you can maybe make it less
important where you just say hey things
are like moving in a direction and then
like the satire i do is like i just do
an extreme version of it and then as
long as we stay on that path we'll get
there you know what i mean
but in terms of like predicting it it's
always like predicting a stock market
right like on a trend is this the top or
is this you know keep going i would say
in my opinion culturally i remember to
some degree i was like switching on some
of the things i was talking about in
like around 2016 and then it felt like
we went back a few years and i would say
right now culturally we're sort of like
we were here right from my hand where
you can see it and then if there was a
peak it sort of went up and then back so
i feel like we're back
uh you know like 20 from the top right
now like without trump it feels a little
a little calmer people aren't as you
know fired up in general so it depends
on what happens next right like does
this go back down or does things get
like fired up the way it is before like
i was loving the idea of just you know
at peak like how much you could just
every family gathering people are
fighting and i was loving the idea of
just going up to a family gathering and
you whatever people think just show up
and go hey who do you guys think is the
bigger hero george floyd or kyle
rittenhouse anyway gotta go to the
bathroom and just
just drink it feel fire there we go
there's this
there's this big chasm
between what we're being told is real on
this but you know george floyd is the
greatest hero or whatever you know
there's this great gasm between
what we're being told by the whole
establishment and the the reality of it
you see this reflected in poll numbers
you see you know biden's at 38 and he's
basically the most popular guy in his
administration uh kamala harris is at 27
which is lower than than dick cheney was
after the iraq war and after shooting a
guy in the face so this is historically
low kind of stuff and yet we're being
told it's the most popular thing ever
it's the most wonderful thing buddha
judge who's now being hailed as the the
next great presidential candidate he was
asked hey what are people supposed to do
about gas prices and he basically said
go buy a tesla with a straight face and
and so what's the react you know what's
the reaction when we're living in this
kind of clown world from the propaganda
of the ruling class and yet we we still
can look around and we still have eyes
to see that that's not what's going on
yeah i feel like every every president
is just like the the like team that
likes them puts out press releases about
how much he's killing it and then yeah
because i remember that with you could
say the same thing with trump where you
know what i mean the left would be like
look here we did a poll and actually
it's negative five percent people like
him and then people will be like and
then you go and it's like everyone from
you know all these states loves them but
biden doesn't have
that's one thing that's like interesting
with people that are like commentary
that like hate biden
you kind of
it's not the same as trump because
they're kind of like i you know he's the
worst or whatever but i feel like he
doesn't have people defending that so
it's not so cut and dry like there's not
even really people that are really
left-wing they're just like i'm just
like abide in head you know what i mean
like my you know what i mean like does
that exist i think even people that like
were super liberal are kind of like you
know maybe like some 60 year old kind of
upper west side types and i think in
general there's no 25 year old that's
all in on buying it no matter what
you're no where in the box i don't even
know what the version of the maga hat
for biden would be you know i like make
it's no it's like a night gap
it's just
just these young people wearing blue
night caps to express their support of
but you don't see it and actually in the
in the polling this is left-wing polls
now of democrats only about 37 percent
even want them to be the nominee going
forward so you don't you don't know
who's going to come up so then i i have
to ask your expert opinion so you kind
of just before so i find whenever it
gets like that then you notice all the
infighting between the sides like i feel
like all the left-wing people are
fighting with each other and all the
right-wing people are fighting with each
other a little bit now don't you haven't
you noticed that like more in the last
four months that's like kind of always
what happens right it was like so clear
who was you know on which side or
whatever and then once it became
wishy-washy everyone kind of looks at
it's like the imagine like being in a
church and then like no one's paying
attention to you anymore and then you're
kind of like
she's having sex without marriage it's
like all these all these people start
arguing with each other and then the
left-wing people are kind of like this
guy doesn't even he's not even a
communist enough
yeah this guy man he's not even wearing
the hammer and sickle this is no good
well yeah so what i what i need to know
from you and your expert opinion in
comedy is
donald it seems to me donald trump was a
very funny president i think he was
probably the funniest prey he had the
dude have you seen his like stuff the
press releases they're
it's not the one that he released the
other day dude i they're so funny he
came out with one it was just like just
want to say that people have the viewer
a bunch of slobs
it's like
there he goes something that was like
the mccain's daughter and he goes you
know and her dad like made me do the
world's longest funeral of all time
it was like
it was gr and the fact that he's like
writing it down and putting it on a
press release is like even funnier the
the fact i remember there was one time
he was at a state dinner he was he was
having dinner with with the queen
and
he sent out a tweet back in those days
when he was still on twitter he sent out
a tweet at what would have been about 1
30 in the morning his time after this
beautiful dinner with the royal family
in which he called bette midler a washed
up psycho
big scout control
so i think okay i think i think trump is
probably the funniest best comedic chops
president we've ever had no obama was
funny you think obama was funny obama
was really funny yeah it was kind of
like they both they both were kind of uh
you know could have been tv presenters
you know i mean i guess trump was but
like no obama was uh comedically like uh
very high level that's like uh
that's why you know obama had everyone
who was they liked him the way that you
know people like trump like trump
because he was like a guy everyone kind
of like wanted to be like he was cool
and he was funny
he did have that line about the predator
drones i thought that was pretty funny
he did that i do remember he did that
bit
for one of the dinners where he
acted as daniel day lewis acting as
barack obama that was that was pretty
funny too but so then looking forward
who is the funniest presidential
candidate that we can look at for 2024.
i know that you said i don't really know
them that well uh but the
the i remember i met andrew yang at the
stand and he's kind of i always thought
it was funny that uh he was he his whole
thing is like you know wearing the math
pin and like kind of nerdy and then when
i saw him he was all like cool he's all
like yeah what's up man like he's like
in new york cool really i didn't realize
that that he was like different in real
life but the um buddha judge i just
remember it is kind of what you said
where they were always it seemed like
every blog was like 10 reasons why he's
so sick and they're like he has a
slingshot he's skateboards like they're
always kind of pushing
they like he's actually pretty sick like
that was kind of the vibe of the push on
bootage head
um so 2024 i guess that's there's kind
of a couple years away it seems like if
the democrats want to win they need like
someone that's very charismatic and kind
of uh cool
i don't know the
republicans i don't know is trump
running you probably have a better
policy so i don't know i mean i look i
think there are good candidates uh on
the right i mean desantis is running
pretty hard i think at this point at the
governor level there's no one can touch
him he's by far the best set up for this
i think at the senate level no one can
touch ted cruz i don't just say cause
we're buddies but he uh you know he's
just got the infrastructure he's done it
before he's kind of leading in the
senate but
sort of the rock yeah well this is the
thing you get these kind of you know
random candidates would be thrown in but
then
none of it really matters in my view
because if trump runs that's it right he
just totally clears the field no one's
going to no one wants to become the next
guy
i think yeah who wants to be in that
yeah if you do
it's just true if you're like a
republican and you want to run and
trump's running you're like ugh i gotta
go have him call my wife fat now
you're talking about how i eat pizza i
mean he trump went on this whole thing
about how how disgusting kasich looks
when he eats a slice of pizza no one
wants to be in that
yeah i don't i think everyone might be
like i guess there's a lot of people
that are hardcore fans but i think he i
think a lot of people even they were
like trump guys kind of don't like him
as much because like the vaccine stuff
right
now well that is true it is a weird spot
that he's in because
a lot of conservative i mean i'm i'm
obviously extremely skeptical of all the
vaccines and having to take the 17th
vouchee you know just to get because
it's so
very effective
so you so you've almost got immunity
yeah you get just a few more and then
you're pretty close
i'll quote my buddy danny polish
uh thing because they're giving everyone
free stuff and he goes new york's like
not the city to be giving people free
ticket free stuff for vaccines and it
was like we're giving hey we're giving
out yankees tickets now and danny said
uh oh uh uh i guess i'm gonna find out
what it what happens when you get 40
doses of this vaccine
did you see in the in the netherlands
there's a brothel that's giving a free
30-minute session
yes no there's a yeah you might be
booking your tickets right now to
holland but they there was this brothel
was giving away
a free 30-minute
sex session
if you took this shot which means that
there are people now who are who are
more pfizer than man at this point i
think
yeah i know dude that stuff's so funny
but yeah i think that i don't know i to
be honest i think that like
who it would be probably even more
tumultuous than before if he goes so i
don't know we'll see but uh
i i think right now it's like a little
calmer i was
i think it's more likely that trump has
a podcast and he's selling like patriot
pills yeah for
you know what i mean
the top tier subscribers to like the
true social and he's selling like
freedom water and stuff like that and
he's just making just making more like
truth social trump i think he quadrupled
his net worth overnight with just like
people pumping that stock
so i don't know why he's just sending
out one price because he can't even put
it on twitter well i guess this this
raises the question about that then
though if the guy is not allowed
on any social media if the guy if the
sec is looking into him and all the kind
of bureaucratic arms are trying to shut
this guy up
i would subscribe to his podcast but are
are they are they going to let him are
they going to let him do anything
who knows i've won you know what a funny
thing was this was
so we're at this like
uh there's this thing in new york and
one of our buddies oh it was like a
fancy like party kind of thing was like
a bunch of rich people right i'm not
really like i don't know these people
but i knew like one guy and then uh
trump one of trump's like daughters was
there and then i guess because of that
the secret service has to like travel
with you so we're at like a party and we
had to go to get like white claws from
like a bodega and the secret service had
to like follow us
i was like this is so i guess they
follow him forever so we're at bodega
and there's like secret service guys
outside of the bodega making sure that
we're safe when we're getting white
claws that is so
that is so embarrassing because as a
fellow just absolute lover of white
claws i consider myself a white claw
aficionado like if you're standing next
to g.i joe you know and you go to the
bodega to order and you order you know
raspberry flavored hard seltzer that
can't that can't make you feel very
masculine no isn't that crazy that that
i didn't i didn't realize that they all
get it forever and and could you imagine
if if he does run again could you
imagine
the
the riots can you imagine just if you
think the
people would have to like dust off their
molotov cocktails like people that you
know left that life and just have like
went back to their normal job and they
have to go back to the closet and be
like all right we're writing again
dust off my twitter fingers and getting
into it
so i don't know
as far as like it feels like that
chapter's closed up a bit and
you know he could uh
it's like he's so you're so old like all
these presents are so old now it's like
i think it's time to potentially do
something else i think well it is hard
if you if the if you're running against
a guy for being
80 joe biden and then you're like look
at it and he's a bit younger he's like
yeah look at this guy he's so old he's
all i i like i'm only 79 as opposed to
this old geezer although trump did have
that lineup a young candidate
when they asked him about biden's age he
did say they said you know he said i'm
not going to attack biden for sage you
know but look all i know is i'm a i'm a
young man i'm a young vibrant
man and uh certainly
there's obviously not a ton of youth or
vibrancy out in most of the political
landscape but what's what's you so
you're in new york you mentioned you
believed it too for sure like if
shambles like he's like writing his
speech he's like dude i'm like young as
hell and everyone's like i don't know
about that he's like what uh you don't
think i'm yet he's got dragon energy him
and kanye they've got he's got it's
pumping through his veins now you so
you're you're in new york you have
you've stayed there you've survived the
smash and grabs and the peaceful arson
and the de blasio administration i live
in the east east village
and it's like
uh it really has become like uh pretty
wild
and when i used to i used to film these
videos on the street and at first it was
like mostly normal people but by the end
it was like the people that kind of just
lived there like took over the park and
this is this is like i said this on
stage but this is the argument that i
heard a guy and a girl have a guy and a
girl we're arguing the girl goes the guy
and she goes hey i showed you the now
give me the mcflurry
[Laughter]
so
these are the kind of deals that are
taking place like outside of my house
this is actually
this is actually true we were just
talking about this but this might be the
canadian in me yeah but there's a guy
and i live in like not by the way not a
you know some like dump right it's like
manhattan you're in a beautiful part of
manhattan very like i realized it's
wildly expensive but it's you know how
new york is right and then outside my
house all these people like smoke crack
and then
i noticed after doing this like three or
four times that i'm very when i walk by
being like hey sorry guys like really
sorry i need to get and now i'm just
like why am i apologizing these people
are smoking crack in my doorway
but they're they're clearly pretty evil
people because i was just thinking about
the guy who bribed the woman to flash
him with the mcflurry everybody everyone
who goes to mcdonald's knows the
mcflurry machine is always broken so if
you're offering a woman that's that's
dark man that's
very deceitful that's his trick he finds
out when the flurry machine's broken and
makes all these mcflurry deals and he
comes back no i'm sorry you're a junior
cheeseburger
there's a filet of fish
i don't have anything so that's
hilarious you move from canada you make
it here to america but now i gotta ask
most of my friends i'm a new yorker born
and raised most of my friends from new
york nashville now i'm in nashville i
left new york i left l.a now i'm living
in the heart of the country a lot of
other people are are you now that you're
an american are you gonna are you gonna
flee new york as well or are you gonna
stick it out
no new york's still the best place in
the world for comedy um i know a lot of
every once in a while unfortunately like
every everyone will always be like
actually there's a comedy scene and you
know memphis they like just pick a place
right
but no it's the the difference is insane
like i do you know the stan and the
comedy cellar and brooklyn comedy club
and like these are
you know the best comedians in the world
and austin has a little pocket you know
of of
of people and every scene has a little
pocket but unfortunately it's like
there's nowhere where you could do five
six sets a night and really be you know
there with the best of the best so it's
just like the same reason if you
you know now it does shift like if you
want to be in tech like i think it used
to be san francisco now you can move to
austin and there's always people moving
and shaking but new york as far as like
art goes as far as comedy goes it's
pretty back to normal it's still
all all of the people
that during covid were like i'm the hell
out of here i'm gonna go you know this
comedy scene i'll be in miami comedy
scene they're all slowly coming back one
by one and being like yeah i mean that's
not really the same thing so it's on
it's unfortunate i mean you know it'd be
obviously better to live somewhere where
you have a big you know house and it's
warm and but it's uh unfortunate i even
went to la like recently and i'm just
like man new york is better comedy it's
just what the situation is so i moved
here specifically for that reason so i
don't think that i would i would leave
for the next little bit unless uh my
life changed drastically and i gave up
on you know trying to be the best of the
best but i think if you want to if
you're in this zone and you're in your
years where you go i want to try to be
the best comedian in the world or one of
the best means in the world i think it's
hard to properly do that somewhere else
uh you're probably right about that so
how
how is the reception obviously you're
super popular you've got about a
bazillion views on youtube but how is
your reception in brooklyn or in
manhattan you know i'm not saying you're
some like buttoned-up tweed-wearing
bowtie conservative but you obviously
contradict a lot of the liberal
orthodoxies that are i think
i think i used to just think it is like
masculine and feminine like but most
people
are uh like pretty receptive like
there's obviously people at every show
and this is i know i like i know that
over the last like little while it was
probably liberals that were
the wild but like you know there's i
would say it's depending on where i am
it's like the conservatives can be just
as bad it's just different topics right
but like and then there's people that
that are there's always like a
difference between like you're trying to
get mad and
you know
right you were trying to get mad and
then you actually were mad because you
know conservatives have their topics
like you know pedophile jokes like troop
stuff like obviously some of that stuff
can be very testy or but sometimes
they'll be like
i've i've been where it's my fault too
where you go do a show and you know
maybe you're too too wild you're talking
about
you know
even it could just be something similar
as like sex stuff and there's like a
whole bunch like way too many old people
in the crowd
and they didn't like it and you could
come away and be like yo they're just
afraid of real con or you could be like
you know what i went into that situation
i did it wrong i didn't tailor it to
right right but that's very and not that
you have to tailor it always but like
that's different than a bunch of old
people saying like hey there's this
comedy show where people are talking
about sex let's go down there and like
be mad right so i think that
so it's it depends on where it is but
most comedy clubs i think people are
fairly receptive to anything that's
funny
definitely i switch a little what i'm
doing based on red states and blue
states because i'm more
my general like tone is to be against
what i'm
talking to right it's kind of like
recipe for success just whatever the
audience is just find a way to piss them
off that's right yeah yeah it really is
but i i even think of it as like think
about with your friends like
imagine you were hanging out with your
friend
and you're all making fun of him but
he's there and then
or like maybe your girlfriend or
whatever and then they leave and you're
all making fun of them and then some
other people that don't know them that
well they're kind of making fun of them
you're like well you don't get to really
do that you're not like well like you
you have to be pretty close to make fun
of them when they're left right so i
kind of think of that the same comedy
principle where it's like
let's say i was doing like a really hard
thing on lgbtq or whatever i wouldn't
want to do that in front of a room of
people that were you know actually
thought gay people shouldn't get married
they had the electrodes in their hands
it was all just mike pence's electrodes
right yeah straight up like gay therapy
stuff but yeah it also felt like it
feels funner to even like you know let's
say you're a trash and trump like that
feels way funner to do at places where
they like him yeah and if you go to
somewhere where they hate him like if
they hate him it feels like gross if you
know you're just pandering at that point
so a lot of times my general uh tone is
to kind of make fun of but do i even
find that
with like
uh
you know like uh even like tv shows or
or friend groups or like music genres
like let's say everyone's into punk
right when everyone's into punk music
and you get together you don't generally
talk about what's wrong with jazz you
kind of talk about what's wrong with
your thing right
so i think that a lot of the stuff that
i've been making fun of even you know
when people were getting wild in the
trump years was like i know these people
and i grew up with them and it's a bit
me to be honest so i think there's kind
of uh i try to have some of that stuff
in the comedy or else it comes across as
um you know more
propaganda and preachy and right right
that's it that's a great that's a great
distinction a profound prophetic as
usual distinction ryan i've already
taken up too much of your time as i
often do
uh but i look forward to the next great
prophecy that you have i'm sure there
will be many more where can people find
you if they haven't found you already um
so i do a podcast every friday called
the boys cast with ryan long um and
there's a and patreon.com the boyscast
and then also i do a video every monday
at youtube.com ryan long comedy and i'm
releasing a stand up special in january
oh also i saw that uh right before i
started i saw you like this tweet but
did you see the jordan peterson in
nashville
it's going to become a woohoo girl on
the back of one of those buses yeah yeah
i like michaela teaches my friend but
it's so funny to me like jordan peterson
like every day he was posting like oh
look at this beer like oh bar is this
much he take one step he's just cruising
around nashville like he's on a
bachelorette party like he's one step
away from having like mardi gras pizza
how funny would be you're just like at a
bar in nashville getting like uh
like just drinking and stuff and you
look over like jordan peterson's on the
dance floor that's so funny it's one of
one of the premier public this is i'm
not making a joke this is just an actual
description of what happened one of the
premier public intellectuals in the
world was at kid rock's big ass honky
tonk and rock and roll steakhouse that's
that's great i i hope i run into jordan
all right go get uh first of all listen
to the boys cast it's awesome it's
really great uh go watch all of ryan's
sketches i look forward to the comedy
special and ryan i will see you soon
thanks man appreciate it peace
[Music]
[Music]